[Applause]
did my daughter Eloise come she left a
note for you you can just read it
ourselves dear Mom I need some pool all
I've ever wanted was to feel like a part
of this family I thought maybe my
wedding would be a chance to reconnect
I see now that maybe we were never
really connected
it's a real shame I know
the truth oh my God have you seen this
invitation are you going to the wedding
Eloise is our half sister which means we
can half-ass the relationship
my rich sister chose to stay in London
and shove fish and chips up her butt
that's not how you eat them
this is nice my company upgraded me very
cool country mouse I figured that
everyone in business class was going to
be hot and mean like you they got
Paddington on this flight
stink
[Music]
my sister's the worst thank you for
coming to England for my nuptials she's
like nataporte and I'm like Nordstrom
Rack Alice the wine dispelling you bet
it is Mom she sounds like a monster so
lovely having you all here only 72 hours
until the big eye too oh my God Alice
I'm fine I think I just had some bad
chicken I have any chicken
it's wonderful being here with my
children and all their friends you know
he's not my friend you know I support
you excuse me sir yes he's my son what's
happening and they do sex things it's
a-okay with me and I'm proud
From This Moment forward you will behave
like a normal family who is here to
happily celebrate a loved one's wedding
is that understood she's even prettier
when she's angry absolutely radiant
[Applause]
[Music]
you know how at every wedding there are
those people Everyone talked about after
cousin Randy oh who are those people
this time
Savage Mom
[Applause]
[Music]
let's begin